is now a good time
you pay the bills mr leon what are you
reading
working on a cure for glioblastoma oh is
that all
and studying it since med school trying
to find a new way in with stem cells
that's admirable
ambitious well i don't think it's as
complicated as everybody makes it out to
be
you don't think utilizing stem cells to
cure one of the deadliest forms of
cancer is
complicated quite self-assured are we
are you not
i'm i'm a realist you gotta believe you
can beat death
otherwise what's the point of doing what
we do well
how was surgery perfect perfect
excellent i heard it went a little long
you heard i did
a little long
do you mind if i ask who you heard that
from oh there's no need to name names
i'm just not used to people talking
about no one's talking
about you unless of course it's to my
face which i encourage
as the chief executive it was that suck
ass circulating nurse wasn't it
i asked how they thought the procedure
went and they reported that it was hope
that you and i are going to have a long
working relationship jill
as i line your pockets with millions of
dollars no then
you will come to trust me if i didn't
trust you i wouldn't have hired you
it went exactly as long as it was
supposed to in order to get it done
right
so there were no complications
i don't have complications every doctor
has complications
not me
okay then it's good to have you aboard
we should grab a bite sometime yeah i'll
bore you with my biography
i'd like that oh do me a favor
of course make sure that door shuts
behind you on the way out
dr dunch what
dorothy burke she's unresponsive can't
palpitate blood pressure's in the
basement
nurses have been trying to reach you one
more
was it you sir cut the sir crap were you
the one talking [ __ ] to deleon
about about how long it took me to
operate on rose keller
and how is mrs keller by the way have
you checked in on her she's doing well
how well
that's not the point no nurse that is
the point you have no clue what it takes
to do what i do yes sir
so why don't you shut your mouth and do
your
job is my aura prep for the madeline
bayer surgery
madeline bayer's surgery is elected and
she elected
to do it today is my or prep
let's push it off focus that's not what
i ask i understand what i don't think
that you do holy prep sir
go prep my or
this isn't right no it isn't we gotta
understand h you need to say
something
[Music]
should we start the cell saver doctor
focus on your job
[Music]
there's a lot of bleeding doctor we
should get an a-line kit
14-gauge iv blood warmer
[Music]
we gotta get this under control doctor
we
you mean me i need to get this under
control yes
doctor you need to get this under
control perhaps we bring in vascular
what's vascular going to do
when you can't get the blood pressure
under control it's not an issue with the
blood pressure why don't we start there
shall we
[Music]
see the disc track
[Music]
i've got it
[Music]
[Music]
ugh
i asked for the charge nurse yeah well
you got the chief of surgery she's my
patient
her treatment is my decision well today
this is my hospital
and when you apply for privileges here
you didn't check the little red box that
said brain surgery you are interrupting
an extremely
delicate spinal fusion oh i'm so sorry i
thought you called for this interrupt
i presumed that you were shrewd enough
to simply sign off well i'm just a
country hick from the bronx so let me
put this in a manner even i can
understand
we don't do craniotomies at this
hospital and you are a guest here at
dallas medical
if one of our staff tells you we don't
have privileges for a procedure it is
not an invitation for debate
i have privileges everywhere across this
city oh you do
i will ensure that not a single patient
comes through wow that would be so
tragic out of my o.r
[Music]
i'm gonna walk you through what's about
to happen
you will complete your work on madeline
bayer she's been open far too long
you will then transfer dorothy burke out
of your care
there will be no more discussion of
craniotomies no more arguments
you will do it and then you will get the
[ __ ]
out of my o.r
[Music]
you're the one who turned me into the
texas medical board
i am
you came for me and i'm still here why
is that
i can't figure out if you're just
incompetent or you're doing all this
on purpose and that makes you insane
did you know people used to say that
nikola tesla
was possessed by demons regular folk had
to come up with a negative label because
they just couldn't comprehend his genius
i've gone over all of your cases and i
don't see any signs of genius
at all that's because you're staring
into the sun
my surgeries were perfect everyone
now circulating nurses
x-ray techs administrators
they can all be so distracting
we've all had complications right even
you robin
willian darp comes to mind doesn't he
it's also human isn't it you look at
someone like me
someone younger smarter
more capable it was filling up all the
spaces
sucking up all the oxygen and then
there's you
tired old
weak i'm gonna revoke your medical
license
well [ __ ] you can try
maybe you'll even succeed but if you
take my license in texas there's still
49 other states
hell there's an entire world out there
and everybody's looking for a good
surgeon with good credentials
but if you come for me you better be
ready for what i'm going to do to you
i will take your money i will take your
career
i will take what little reputation
you've ever had
you want to hit me
well go ahead robert i'm right here
me
[Music]